sense of why you're sitting here why
utah was willing to trade you
uh that's a good question i think you
know i think um
i mean obviously losing queen uh queen
was you know was there for eight years
was a big part of what we were doing
you know there's uh sometimes there's uh
some the window for winning is
not always big and then
first in utah that's kind of what
happened you know i think the
organization felt like that
we had maybe past that window that we
had over the last few years and
and i think they still obviously going
to be a very competitive team but
they just felt like with all the assets
that they could get with me
um that it was better for them to to go
that way and uh you know and i think it
could potentially be a a win-win
situation when
you know uh they also put me in a great
situation to win and and for me that's
why i'm really grateful for that you
know that they put me in a
in on a team that i can you know
keep flourishing and and hopefully win a
championship and then